could you make money by writing online
or you might think it's Out Of Reach but
online writing expert Nicholas Cole
believes that now is the perfect time to
make a living as a writer you know when
I was in school my teachers which I
always found weird and ironic but they
always said not everyone can become a
writer and I kind of sat in class and I
was like well then why are we all here
and I think Legacy writing has this
elitism to it where it's like not
everyone can do it and you have to
suffer and you have to stack rejection
letters and you only are rewarded if
you're brilliant and like it's there's
all this red tape and the world of
digital writing now is anyone can become
a writer all of these skills are easy to
learn and it's possible you just need to
invest the time to learn some of these
skills and put them into practice